that and also much example of gradual
ations a three American Music Awards
yeah yeah just over there but do they
think of you as as British or you just
like a big pop act I didn't think it was
as British don't they yeah yeah and
Irish Irish of course yes sorry no wow
that would have been letters believe
Graham Norton said
and it must be a thrilling night lovely
they won they won so many prizes and yet
what's my little anger afterwards where
they felt a buck upstaged by Zayn's hair
now we're on the mat now had you planned
the loose strand no it kind of just fell
that way just fell that yeah I mean it
looks lovely it looks lovely it works
but if quick Twittersphere
melts down about this hair here's just a
selection of some of the tweets that
they say in single strand of hair is
prettier than my entire
we haven't seen the person it could be
true it's another one Saenz hair is the
reason what what connects what's that I
love this stains here tonight is why I
still
this this is devious is you someone was
just so moved all the cheap was this I
love your strangled eyes out
died his shoulder
you're amazing right out so are you
guess we should get a tattoo on your
penis with the word el dente on it